point isn't to win at marriage or win at
business or win at Health the point is
to stay healthy the point is to continue
your marriage the point is to stay in
the game of business and so the only way
you lose in business is quitting if you
think of life as an infinite game point
of the game isn't to finish the game
right because that I mean the point of
the game would be to die the point of
the game is to keep the game going and
that's the difference between an
infinite and a finite game so finite
game has known players two teams agreed
upon rules and a set outcome where it
ends infinite games has known and
unknown players no agreed upon rules and
the only point of the game is to keep
the game going and so as long as you
stay in the game you have more Innings
you have unlimited Innings and so the
only way you lose this topic so don't
stop